l'été touche à sa fin ah je sais ça fait
pas plaisir mais c'est comme ça toujours
est il que c'est le moment idéal pour
flâner au soleil cueillir quelques murs
se battre et avoir les doigts violets
ont marqué un peu énervant les tâches de
murs et pourtant il ya pire
il ya vraiment vraiment pire tout l'été
des tissus vous aident à éviter les
pièges et les dangers qui menacent votre
bien-être et votre santé
il était fier partenaire de votre été si
je vous dis peña vous me dites ah oui le
ver solitaire
ah oui le ver solitaire voilà si je vous
dis peña du renard vous dise je m'en
fous j'suis pas un renard m'en fous je
suis pas un renard et voilà non et
surtout vous me dites à temps mais quel
rapport avec maintenant mais quel
rapport et que tu arrive maintenant à
arrêter un type lcd
[Musique]
et
bon on a été ou alors le rapport entre
le ténia le renard les murs et mou je ne
sais pas vous explique le kenya du
renard est quoi le ténia du renard c'est
une maladie dont le nom scientifique et
l'échinococcose alvéolaire
elle est causée par un parasite qui
s'appelle l'échinococcose dutil au cul
larry et ciné vous pas à élire domicile
dans l'intestin des renards les
spéciales moi je préfère quand c'est un
peu plus lumineux mais bon on n'est pas
chez stéphane plaza
l'autre particularité de l'échinococcose
multilocularis et de pauvres une
quantité de à ses faramineuses qu'on
retrouve ensuite dans le caca des
renards commence à voir venir non et oui
pourquoi qu'un renard un tant soit peu
le chenapan voir sa crypte où il a créé
vaut rien quoi ou pierre renard donc et
était pris d'une violente en doute
déféquer en passant devant le bosquet
duriez que vous vous apprêtez à
dévaliser
vous avez un risque de vous retrouver en
train de vie noté bb plein 2d qui
notons-le sus multilocularis alors vous
me direz ce oif et alors non et alors le
problème c'est que c'est eux ne vous
était pas destiné normalement c'est des
petits rongeurs corps et vous les mangez
et les auraient pu gentiment se
développer bien au chaud dans leur foi
devenir des larves à 100 car renard
bonzes le rongeur en question élire
domicile dans l'intestin du renard et
pondre leurs oeufs
mais du coup la fée vous qui avait mangé
les donc les larves elles vont se
développer dans votre foi mais vous
n'allez sûrement pas vous faire manger
par un renard donc les larves elles vont
continuer à grandir à l'en-tête envahir
vos poumons cerveau don d'organes au
tour en suisse
mais la séance passée pendant 5 et 15
ans et puis les premiers signes vont
apparaître mal au ventre perte de poids
fatigue des si monsieur va pas très fort
au niveau du foie le problème c'est qu'à
ce stade les dégâts sont déjà bien lourd
et que si on ne fait rien ça on meurt
pour une mue rocade renard comment
éviter de choper le ténia du renard car
oui du coup j'imagine que maintenant
vous allez invité à manger des murs ou
tout autre
ce sera dommage d'abord parce que bon
nous perdons et ensuite parce que bonne
nouvelle d une maladie rare dray on
parle de 10 à 15 cas par an en france et
en plus des renards infectés
il y en a pas dans toutes les régions en
france par exemple cela concerne les
régions du centre et de l'est mais on en
trouve aussi en suisse en autriche en
allemagne et aux pays bas
le problème si vous tenez absolument à
manger des fruits des bois c'est que ni
le lavage nuit la congélation ne tue les
là que la cuisson soit efficace alors si
vous n'aimez pas les confitures curinier
vauban en hauteur c'est à dire un
endroit où même un renard très vénère et
très agile ne peut pas déféquer et quand
c'est trop tard
on fait quoi bon comme on l'a vu quand
on s'en rend compte en général les
larves sont déjà bien entraîner dans ces
cas-là il ya deux solutions
l'opération qui consiste à retirer les
parties infecté voire infectés par le
parasite est parfois l'obligation
d'avoir recours à une greffe d'organe de
fois notamment
et il ya aussi des traitements sous
forme de médicaments mais qui ne font
que ralentir le développement des
bestioles sans les suit donc c'est à vie
je suis lent gens sans moi je m'en fous
un passager blanc voilà des ses
spécialités est fini on se retrouve à la
rentrée pour une nouvelle vidéo
d'ici là vous connaissez la chanson
mettez vous bien et puis surtout portez
vous bien
[Applaudissements]